做出一個七八糟的東西出來
所以我們必須要做好我們的Hudders
我們來看一下
先放這個
今天AI的編程太厲害
AI的Agent太厲害
一個公司要往前走
需要把大量的AI員工帶進來
帶進來的第一個問題就是
你在公司有誰會晚會去操作
會去指導
會去orchestrate這一批AI員工
這些人要幫他找出來
如果公司裡面沒有就要招進來
這是第一個需要做的
第二個就是如果公司AI員工越來越多
有些真的學不會有AI
管理AI員工只會管理人
而且管理的過程中
可能更多的是官僚的信息的上傳下達
對還有人的彼此的認知
然後甚至玩一些落手工程的政治游戲
那這些人也要早點識別出來
讓他們開始離開公司
完全去AI那一條
對而且公司的員工
大部分是AI員工
可能80% 90% 95%
當然這不代表人就會失業了
人至70% 80% 90%
因為也許我們的業務漲了10倍
漲了100倍
所以也許員工還獲當
只是AI員工
一定是越大於人的數量
因為我們的所有的員工
他們能做的任務越來越多
AI可以做的更快更好更業
比如說你在抖音看到一個
哇我覺得他講的好好啊
這是我想講的東西
怎麼能夠把它轉成你的呢
對吧
真的就發一句命令給AI就可以了嗎
那個不太現實啊
所以我簡單做了一下
因為我也不是做自媒體
也不是做視頻的
但是我在學習一個
它工程太厲害了
AI agent太厲害了
一個公司要往前走
需要把大量的AI員工帶進來
帶進來的第一個問題就是
你家公司有誰會管
會去操作
會去指導
會去orchestrate
這一批AI員工
這些人要幫他找出來
如果公司裡面沒有
就要招進來
我這個呢
一句話沒改
我就發給AI就搞定了
那背後你甚麼原理呢
為甚麼可以這樣啊
其實呢
背後是非常
複雜的一個hardness體系啊
所以你沒有hardness呢
你根本控制不出
它到底做出來的
聲音能不能跟你一模一樣啊
對吧
它的文字和那個
那個語音的對齊度
夠不夠高啊
對吧
它的內容會不會有變啊
等等等等啊
但是你有hardness呢
你就可以
下次再找一條視頻
再餵給它一句話
它又出來了
OK
那怎麼來做呢
我們來看一下
這只是一個案例啊
回去呢
如果你想做小紅書
它也有一堆流程
一堆harness在裡面
對吧
但是呢
這就是一個
我們說的這個harness體系啊
第一步你要找到你原始的視頻
還是文稿
對吧
然後呢
叫做去AI位很重要
如果是
我這個是直接複製啊
跟我要發一篇文章去AI位不一樣啊
但是我之前做的
是需要改寫的
對
就是它也不文章
然後你讓AI改寫
結果寫出來
很AI位
所以你第一個skill裝完了
skill它就是harness的一種
OK
你agent呢
是告訴這個這個員工
他是做甚麼工作的
skill他有甚麼技能
對吧
然後接下來
你再創一些harness
就是你在用這些技能的時候
你要遵守甚麼規則
就是你是一個老闆
對吧
我公司
就是我的
你這個員工
agent
skill甚麼技能
對吧
接下來做的事情
有甚麼限制
每一個環節我都用react
把它跑一個mvp
react甚麼東西啊
邊走邊看嘛
對吧
剛剛講了
第一個架構
你不要一來就
pand and execute
太貴了
對吧
你不要一來就multi-legion
你都不知道你要乾嘛
你乾嘛multi-legion
對吧
你先react
每一個環節跑一遍
第一個環節
去AI位
檢查一下內容行不行啊
不行的話
哪裡不行啊
那個harness
是要講清楚規則了
然後把這個去AI的skill
位給他
第一關
跑通了
把它close掉了
就是第一個loop了
第一個完成了
下一個loop
我要配音
那我就要找啊
我嘗試找了
很多收費很貴
又沒有cli的
我全部排除了
因為它不能大量的生成
不能很方便的自動化的生成
所以我必須要找一個有cli的
並且我讓我的agent
寫成腳本
api
我每次一調一篇文稿過去
它直接調用那個cli和api
直接訓練
訓練完返回給我
就是我的配音了
ok
這一步又close掉了以後
我後面不用再訓練這個語音了
它就能自己搞了
ok
這個就是這個fish audio
可以大家去研究一下
國外最厲害的其中一個
無論是做配音還是數字能的
它有cli
重點就是它能夠給你自動化
第四個分鏡
它能不能夠幫你做
我是做PPT
英文教學為主
這一次
包括我的助教
都是教學為主
PPT的登鏡
PPT的動畫
然後hyperframe
這個也是很出名的
Codex裡面的一個工具
幫你剪視頻
以前我們的剪視頻太痛苦了
對吧
打開剪印每一秒
每一幀在那裡調調調
那個語音還要對齊對吧
現在我
一個管件都沒有打開
它剪的全部對齊的
就是你的hunners要寫好
ok
然後再來
這裡就要檢查了對吧
不然你如果錯了一個最後成篇了
你再去改很費錢
所以你一定要在每一個環節
哪一個環節很關鍵的時候
你要給它設置很多審查
包括語意有沒有問題啊
佈局有沒有問題啊等等
檢查完了再推字幕
慢慢的
給封面
發佈
自動化發佈
最後交付
這個機器人就close掉了
ok
close掉以後呢
你後面有甚麼抖印字
你直接發給它
它就會做了
然後再來呢
你選模型
這裡面
對吧
簡單的
給lunner
複雜的
有衝突
要解決bug的
給這個
受啊
就你去選模型
每一個close
你都可以跟Hunless
寫清楚
我執行這個loop的時候
我要掉便宜的
然後我執行這個loop
我要掉貴的
因為它比較複雜
ok
都可以寫在Hunless裡面
好
接下來了
我的助教又來了
我們來看一下啊
Hunless到底是甚麼
深刻理解一下
一個AI模型
在兩個項目里
表現卻像兩種
完全不同的產品
有的agent
接到一句任務
就能自己找資料
改文件
跑測試
最後把結果交回來
另一個
卻不斷追問
改完
又把原來的功能弄壞
差別
很多時候
不在模型本身
而在模型外面
那套工作系統
這套系統
叫Hunless
Hunless Engineering
就是為AI agent
搭建工具
環境
和反饋機制
OpenAI團隊做過一個內部實驗
從空倉庫開始
讓Codex
參與生成代碼
測試
文檔
CI
和內部工具
最後
形成約100萬行倉庫內容
和1500個pool request
這個案例不是效率承諾
它真正說明的是
模型能寫代碼以後
人的工作開始上移
把目標說清楚
給Agent能用的工具
再把反饋
做成它可以執行的規則
理解Hunless之前
先把三個詞分開
Prompt Engineering
!關心這句話怎麼說
Context Engineering
!關心模型此刻能看到哪些資料
Hunless Engineering
再往外一層
它規定Agent能調用甚麼工具
擁有甚麼權限
按甚麼流程執行
以及失敗以後怎麼回來
Prompt
是一張指定卡
Context
是工作台上的材料
Prompt
是整間工廠的運行方式
先看Prompt
一個清楚的提示詞
會寫明目標
背景
輸出格式
和限制條件
這能明顯改善一次回答
但它沒有持續執行能力
任務跨過多輪以後
模型還要讀文件
調用工具
檢查結果
甚至處理失敗
繼續把所有要求
塞進一條超長提示詞
只會讓這張指定卡
越來越難維護
接下來是
Context Engineering
它要做的不是把資料全部塞進去
而是篩選
壓縮
排序和更新
模型準備改一個登錄模塊時
需要看到當前需求
相關代碼
架構規則
和最近的錯誤記錄
不需要同時讀完整個公司的知識庫
好的 上下文
像一張地圖
先告訴Agent去哪裡
需要細節時
再按目錄深入
這叫漸進披露
到了Harness
問題從模型看甚麼
變成整個系統
怎樣完成工作
左邊是目標
規範
知識
和當前計劃
中間的Agent
根據這些信息做判斷
右邊是命令
文件
API
Skills
和全線邊界
執行結果
不會直接結束
測試
評審
和日誌
會把結果重新送回
下一輪上下文
所以Harness
更接近一個控制系統
它把理解
執行和反饋
連成閉環
Agent第一次做錯很正常
真正影響可靠性的
是它能不能從錯誤里恢復
一條完整面路
從意圖開始
經過計劃
執行和驗證
驗證通過就交付
驗證失敗
要返回錯誤證據
修復路徑和停止條件
再更新計劃
如果連續失敗
預算超限
!或者遇到權限
與高風險判斷
就轉交給人
目標不是無限重施
而是讓每一次失敗
都帶回新信息
把Hunless拆開
至少能看到六類部件
第一是支持地圖
讓Agent找到權威資料
第二是規格和計劃
記錄目標
邊界與決策
第三是工具和Skills
把重復動作做成可復用流程
後面還有測試與評價
架構約束
觀測與恢復
OK
好
大家大概有個概念
其實能不能用好AI呢
現在有很多人
屬於
哇
屬於毛球池
就是
很多細節
我一直讓AI做出來
一直給他
這個截圖
那個細節
一直跟他對話
對吧
這樣其實很累
你那個人呢
就在裡面loop了
對吧
那個loop裡面
就是你
在裡面給任務
你就是那個Hunless
對吧
所以要改變這個現狀呢
你要給他一個完整的Hunless
的所有文件
然後你是管理他
而不是命令他
命令他實在是太痛苦了
OK
而且最後不可能
能給你交付一個超於你預期的東西
因為你在控制他
他最多就是給你交付
你想象中的東西而已
最多最多
但是你做好Hunless
他能做到超乎你的想象
那網站
他可以用最好的東西給你做出來
比如說
哇
怎麼這麼厲害
但你的Hunless寫的好
你就能實現這樣的一個現狀
所以呢
做一條視頻呢
他有很多的步驟
包括甚麼對嘴型
這些hyperframe
所以這個不是說
我來教你們做視頻
而是告訴你這個步驟
你是要去善於
拆解任務的步驟
找到合適的skill和工具
然後最後寫好Hunless
這個才是你們要掌握的技能
OK嗎
你們有很多的任務場景
所以我說AI課跟普通課不一樣
對吧
第一次看到一個課呢
聯名層可以跨越這麼大
然後行業呢
也可以跨越這麼大
對吧
你是做每個行業的
每個人都不一樣
但是AI呢
就是你要學底層的邏輯
底層的知識
你才能把他用好
所以是各行各業各種年齡
都需要學的一個東西
OK
那學甚麼呢
就是怎麼去寫好你的Hunless
而找到合適的工具
好
還有很多我這次準備這個課程
對我收穫最大的就是我在跨界做了很多AI的試試
這個也是我自己的收穫
OK
那核心就是你怎麼輸入一些你想要的東西給他
他可以像彭總經常提的
可以拆考對吧
可以模仿
最後呢
你給他Hunless
告訴他要怎麼改
怎麼做
最後做成你要的
好
這些只是一個案例
都不用去細看
這只是我在做的時候
對吧
給他Hunless 1
定個風格
Hunless 2
去AI 用到這個
Skill
對吧
Hunless 3
用我這個語音
錄好一段
寫好腳本
下一次
幫我
有文章過來
全部在調用這個API
直接
複製一段語音出來就結束了
然後對嘴型
這個是我用過
有CLI的可以用
對吧
我講那麼多話
同一個動作
他嘴型就可以跟著那個文字了
CLI可以自動用
那都是需要充一點點錢的
Hyperfirm
就是Codex裡面的剪印
你都不用去剪
我一秒鐘都沒剪過
OK
就是他自動剪了
最後
哪裡做的不好
哪裡有問題
每一層都要保留證據
告訴AI
這裡就是有問題
對不起
說的
那個
很多問題
風格不對甚麼
一層一層的
react完了
再把它
做出來
好
然後呢
也要做版本迭代
就是
你慢慢的會發現
你在寫Hunless
做這些文件的時候
會生了一堆
試錯的文件
你的C盤D盤會瘋狂爆炸
所以你定期就要更新版本
所以我前面其實很多是試錯的
幫我
對吧
你手動刪也可以
把Hunless 1做過的試錯文件
它不屬於會調用
和不屬於證據方面的東西
全部刪掉
然後提煉出來
做成Hunless版本2
對吧
就是版本的迭代
跟你流程中的一個一個環節
都可以去設置你的Hunless
OK
好
所以最貴的呢
其實不是出錯
所以我們說
複雜的系統
一定要從縮小它
從小的部件開始做
確保每個小的沒有出錯
你才能
把它拼裝成一個大的系統
所以我們說
最貴的不是出錯
而是出錯到最後才發現了
那你可能要重做
OK
好
這個是我做這個視頻
處理了最久的一個Hunless
那你們可能有不同的任務啊
到時候你們就是
一定要保留證據
並且呢
用電腦能
能看得懂的規則
告訴他
我這個Hunless
要怎麼改
好
有時候這些Hunless
也會出現一些問題啊
所以呢
在寫規則的時候
不是寫了
它就一定會執行的
甚至他有時候會會有一些
就是你第二次在窮富掉
要問他的時候
還是會出錯了
所以這個你一定要
對吧
指向
指向失敗的證據
告訴他這個
這個這個問題在哪
那他下一次不要再犯這個錯啊
這個是可以去實現的
好
那簡單來說呢
對這些就是我們
我們做的一個具體的事情
就是把它寫成規則
但這個也不需要你寫
也是讓AI寫
所以無論是調用
命令堂也好
寫它也好
你不要想的很複雜
現在都不複雜
就是讓AI寫
你只要講清楚能話就可以了
好
其實呢
更實際的是呢
我們來操作一遍這個Harness
那我本身呢
在網站上面
已經給他準備了一個小案例
但我估計呢
大部分人都沒
也有安裝這個這個這個
這個Codex
但不會把你應該也可以
OK
我們呢
就是在創建一個員工的時候
第一個步
就第一步就可以了
最關鍵的是甚麼步驟
我們來看了
現在呢
我們是一家
50人的
羊的跟羊的這個公司
小游戲公司
那未來的老闆呢
最常面對到的問題會是甚麼呢
就是這個月
員工用的AI的Token
費用怎麼這麼貴
是吧
到底用在哪裡了
有沒有創到收益
那我怎麼來做一個
財務的Agent呢
好
這裡呢
你看
我已經把數據弄好了呀
打開這個數據
我已經下轉到本地了
其實呢
哎
就在這裡
第一周
我只是把一個
最常規的一個創建
Hunners的步驟給他演示一下
就你在做一個項目之前
啥也不要做
就是把案子寫好
OK
我看到一個報表啊
這個是我老闆給我發的
哦
說這個月
員工用了6800的那個Token費用啊
然後呢
是效率
花了
省了260個小時
然後數據的完整都呢
是94%啊
這個是
你會返回工作的
然後有沒有被驗證過
主要就是這個Bug
Bug
那個返回率
有9次啊
這個月
好
那你看到這個表
我想說
老闆每周都給我發這個哦
那我可能每周都自己弄滿的
很辛苦
那我要怎麼做呢
做一個Agent 出來了
這兩個呢
就是AI創建的
我直接就打開這個了
所以呢
你做任何的Agent之前呢
你要先讓AI瞭解你
這是第一步
然後呢
再來寫一些規則
所以呢
你可以看到
這個案例是最最最最簡單的了
所以你們回去
你看
這個都已經做好了
直接就是
放在這裡
對吧
我來讀我老闆這個
AI費用的這個
這個CSV
然後我要創建一個VB
就讓他更懂我的
這個項目就是做這樣的公司背景啊
有會經常收到甚麼CSV啊
對吧
然後有甚麼經營目標的使用方法
然後第二個呢
就是Agent.MD
那他呢
會有甚麼限制
老闆說
每個月不能超過8000塊
數據完整度要不高
反功率不能超過兩次
然後經營的建議
你必須人工審核等等等等啊
這些都是你們
可以幫AI去寫的
所以我這邊複製完
發給AI
他就自動給我創建了這兩個
MD文件
MD文件就是Mockdown文件啊
就是計算機訊的讀文檔的
所以你每次乾一個Agent之前
先給背景
再寫第一個Harmus
就是Agent
規則
然後呢
他就搞定了
寫好了
那這個是我們說的VSCode啊
就是可以了打開不同類型的一些文件
你看CSP也可以在這裡開
數據在這
然後呢
Bitme
這個公司的背景
他都寫好了
然後數據的樣式
對吧
這代表甚麼數據
費用啊
完整度啊
反功率啊
寫好了
這就是我們說的第一
第一個Agent
不是
第一個Harmus啊
這只是給他一個案例啊
那第二個Harmus呢
就是他的Agent.MD啊
他不能
如果超出了
要報警等等啊
好
那第二周來了
老闆就給了個數據了
老闆給了數據了
我這裡呢
要點一下這個
完成了完成了
寫了兩個Harmus
然後Pump 2呢
直接展開
複製給他
對吧
這一周要做甚麼啊
因為多了一個新的數據出來
並且有一些問題呢
呃
發現了
那我們直接發給他就可以了
他會有一個自動的
一個Memory的體系
他就直接在這文件裡面
他就能讀到這兩個
八蛋文件去做
作為他的硬
硬帆的
就是硬控的
他每次
啊
運行新任務的時候呢
他都會
知道你有甚麼
Agent啊
MD啊
這種事情
好
我這裡呢
為甚麼他又這麼慢呢
我又習慣了用最貴的模型啊
所以呢
他就是比較慢的
但是呢
剛剛有人說
啊
那我用GPT不是很貴嗎
等等等等
那你要先搞清楚一個事情
我們說A到B點
對吧
你用便宜的模型
就等於
我用破拉拉再拉貨
對吧
A到B
然後呢
你的貨很多
結果破拉拉了
來回拉
來回拉拉了
幾百次
對吧
才把貨拉完了
那如果你用最貴的模型
可能就是一個大卡車
可能拉一次
就結束了
OK
所以你除了看貴以外
你還要看你的
項目
有沒有價值
再來呢
反攻率
對吧
如果反攻率高
你人投入的時間就更多了
那你是不是
你的時間的價值
是不是比這個Token還要便宜啊
這個是你要考慮的點啊
所以為甚麼昨天那個博士也說
啊
我們做科研
全都用最最
最頂級的
受害了
對吧
那因為他們真覺得這東西
反攻率低
這是關鍵的
那他推理的時候也會比較慢
而且我網絡
怎麼回事
可能太多人在用了
但沒事
我只要告訴大家步驟
就是你在乾一件事
不要直接發PAM給AI了
先讓他瞭解你
並且寫好控制條件
這才是第一步
OK
好
沒事
他待會
待會再看吧
反正他會幫你
找出問題
並且修改你的Hunnas
變成V2的版本
然後呢
你下次再來數據
你又可以重復掉用了
就不用再浪AI
又泡一次
又要說
我是甚麼甚麼
又要講一遍
那就很痛苦
OK
所以關鍵的呢
不是說這個例子
有甚麼可以學習
而是說
真正這個步驟很重要
你用PAM
去讓他寫規則
去創建這兩個文件
才是關鍵的
好
慢慢回去
你們有興趣可以嘗試一下
反正自己有新的項目想做
第一個步驟
就是要讓人家先瞭解你
好
其實這裡呢
其實這裡呢 也就是大家回去多嘗試多使用才會能夠真正學習到
所以到這裡有沒有什麼問題啊
因為接下來我們就會講一些比較技術的東西
包括多Agent 包括現在最前面的一些AI開發
OK 所以呢 到這裡我們再休息一會 有沒有問題呢 可以提
嗯嗯嗯嗯
好
沒有的話我們
好休息五到十分囉
OK